[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to it may
surprise some of you that I'm actually a
huge fan of the jungle book no no not
that one no no not that one either the
actual book it's surprising how many
people don't know there's a literary
source to the jungle book the classic
collection of stories by BR Kipling
mostly tackled the ongoing separations
yet parallels between abandonment and
fostering law and freedom and the
coming-of-age of balance between trying
to belong yet also trying to stand out
then this came along and became the
funny monkey movie and before you go
nuts
I like this film fine the animated
Disney adaptation had little connection
to the best-known story from The Jungle
Book Mowgli's Brothers but it was a cute
little flick with some catchy songs and
memorable characters and seeing how
we're still in the middle of Disney's
live-action remake month it only figures
to talk about I'll just say it what I
think is a weirdly beloved modern
version
so what most of these Disney remakes are
big hits there's usually a fair amount
of people who fight they can't get into
what the movie is doing Jungle Book is
one of the few exceptions sitting at 95
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and getting a
reputation as the grownup version
compared to the other ones only a
complete asshole would dare badmouth it
yeah I'm that jerk-off and not only
didn't like it but really didn't like it
surprisingly it's not because it wasn't
enough like the book the original film
did that and it was fine it's that it
tries to mix the book and the movie by
focusing on their least effective
elements while leaving out what made the
other version so memorable
what are these elements well as your
designated asshole I'm excited to expand
on this different point of view among a
sea of disapproving comments that's a
good start let's take a look at 2016
Jungle Book suffers you might be
wondering why the logo looks and
aesthetically hand-drawn even though
this is live-action especially when
there's already a nostalgic Lee
hand-drawn logo they're not using this
is the confusing tone that all
accompanied the next 90 minutes oh let's
whisk it forward to the middle no wait
this is apparently clever okay just
starting us off in the middle of things
I guess a lot of stories do that let's
see what it adds
you must be the very worst wolf I've
ever seen
oh we can fake out we all saw coming
anything else I'm gonna take this talk
about trees as know there is nothing
else so why do we have this generic
intro the opening to both the book and
the animated film are simple
straightforward and reveal a lot of
character
within the first few moments we know
Mowgli is an abandoned baby a predator
has the chance to kill him but doesn't
creates a connection showing love and
care and shows clearly that this is
unusual and even risky yet they still
take that chance on this connection but
help with that nonsense we have the
opening to u.s. marshals yeah remember
that sequel to the fugitive you don't
remember they start off with a bland
action sequence with the main character
that doesn't tie in to the rest of the
movie a lot of shitty films do that but
to be fair they don't already have a
perfectly written intro laid out for
them and I know it seems like a lot to
harp on so early but the other intros
really do suck you in it shows you who
they are how they became this way and
how their world works this one rather
than showing you tells you when I found
him many years ago it was just an
infinite abandoned in the woods
why entrust it into the wall the book
had a lot of explaining about its
environment too but it was done through
Mowgli's eyes as the newcomer if he
didn't follow these rules he'll die were
emotionally invested here it sounds like
what you study for a test
Akilah was a just and Noble leader and
the water truce was caught it was a rock
show who raised him it had been many
many years since the Peace Rock was
revealed by law of the jungle
drinking concrete for eating critic how
does the law of the jungle go oh I
pledge allegiance lost by the way see if
you can tell which lines are from one of
the greatest literary minds who ever
lived and which ones are Disney writers
trying to make their five-year-old laugh
for the strength of the pack is the wolf
and strength of the wolf is the path
there's a rock that's my rock that's my
rock the wolf that keeps them may
prosper but the wolf that breaks it will
die that's pretty hard to tell right at
least the other one didn't even try they
knew that lines like this I do not call
you my brothers anymore but dogs I see
that you are indeed dogs when mixed with
lines like this they were saving the
more grown-up version for the sequel
Mowgli play by Neel Sethi forms a strong
friendship with Bagheera voiced by Ben
Kingsley until their credit everybody in
this film acts fine even once chosen to
act bad are surprisingly pretty good but
we'll get to that in a bit the
technology is very impressive too as it
truly is hard to believe that all of
this takes place inside a studio but the
characters in world building are still
very strange
for example Scheer convoys by Aegis Elba
comes to drink from the water on the day
of peace it makes a little sense and
isn't from the book but I'll give it a
pass for at least trying this out adult
a man-cub becomes man and man is this
Shere Khan is odd in the original story
he's a screaming bloodthirsty thug but
still follow the laws of the jungle in
the end of may 1 he's calm and
sophisticated but does whatever he wants
for the thrill of it here they tried to
combine the two and it just doesn't add
up
he has an elegant vocabulary but he's
always dirty and covered in mud
imagine if the anime one looked like
that he looked ridiculous you're trying
my patience he also goes on and on about
following the law of the jungle and then
Mowgli should be killed because man is
too dangerous but we'll get to that in a
moment just remember I said that for now
there's concern about whether or not the
law abiding Shere Khan will not harm
Mowgli it was a question that counsel
had to face
they deliberated and they argued for
many days it was more interesting when
they showed this discussion but school
is not supposed to be fun of what they
may call you you will always be feel
free to return to share our incredible
moments like hearing Bagheera talk about
our incredible moments some Oakley
agrees to leave to keep the Wolves safe
but Bagheera says he's gonna take him to
the man village which Mowgli doesn't
want to go to Shere Khan separates them
though as Mowgli tries hiding among the
wildebeest stampede
I saw another Disney film like this
doesn't end well for the cat Mowgli gets
away though which should make sure Khan
happy seeing how he's finally out of the
jungle but he returns to the wolves and
well kills their leader and holds them
hostage until Mowgli returns but should
I have the man-cub these hills of my
hills okay this brings me back to what I
was saying before now this might sound
like a dumb question at first but really
think about it like actually think it
over
why does sheer Khan want Mowgli in the
originals because he lives among them
that makes sense he thinks he's gonna
grow into a man and kill them in the
anime one is for the thrill of the hunt
he loves the challenge and smiles
whenever he even hears the mention of
man I'm going to close my eyes and count
to ten it makes the chase more
interesting for me here I don't really
know if he can do whatever he wants like
in the anime one why didn't he just get
Mowgli at the watering hole nobody's
stopping him from taking over the walls
so nobody would stop him there if he
follows the rules like in the book he
just threw those out the window when he
killed the Wolves leader and it doesn't
matter cuz Mowgli is out of the jungle
anyway there's no threat either way
there's no reason for him to want this
damn kid not in character motivation or
logical survival I know they're trying
to be the grown-up version but when the
adult version can't answer why and the
kid version can you're pretty much
becoming DC but don't worry their
version of Kai's sure to win you over
yeah you remember him arguably pointless
but so much fun to watch you wouldn't
dream of filming a jungle book movie
without him it was funny but also had
the predatory creepiness to him I think
we need the Pooh
across with Herbert from Family Guy you
don't want me to look at you I know what
you're trying to do he had two lengthy
scenes in the anime one so let's see
what they do of him here well first of
all he's a she now played by Scarlett
Johansson poor sweet okay okay odd but
see where they're going with this she
for no reason I configure tells him that
surecount killed his father then tries
to eat him but it's knocked out by Baloo
the bear and that's it no more calm
under two minutes of no jokes no songs
not even really any character but man
does she use those plot points for
hypnotizing people that leave no
impression on our main character like he
doesn't even bring up oh it sucks I sure
can't kill my dad and it looks like he
just forgets about it through most of
the movie so which one is really better
the silly little kid version that no one
remembers or the super complex dark and
gritty grown-up version what the hell
are you people oh by the way is that the
motivation for why sure Kyle wants
Mowgli so bad he wants to go after the
offspring of the man who burned his face
uh he already killed the guy I don't see
what going after the offsprings gonna do
is he also gonna say screw the law of
the jungle and my livelihood because I
didn't get the son of an antelope or the
daughter of a quail or the nephew of a
zebra this is still dumb if this is it
relax kid no need to get worked up okay
so Bill Murray plays Bill Murray voicing
a bear playing Bill Murray
you owe me kid you owe me I guess his
distinct voice can be a little
distracting but if you never heard
little John when watching the original
you were lying to your soul as payback
for a saving Mowgli's life but who uses
him to climb up a mountain to get him
honey telling him the bees don't sting
you said back off man I'm a scientist
so Mowgli decides to head to the man
village yeah I guess he's okay with
going there again and Baloo says he'll
show him the way you can always tell by
the red flower the red flower doesn't
seem so bad yeah let it loose and it
destroys everything it touches kind of
weird how he calls fire the red flower
but a moment earlier he used the word
propaganda that's not a song that's
propaganda
guess they got a lot of Michael Moore
movies in the jungle
[Applause]
[Music]
loulou convinces mowgli to stay with him
in the jungle as they sing a familiar
tune that's a song about the good life
yeah and the other version they were on
song three but I guess this is a good
time to do our first I do like that
Mowgli puts devices together to help get
food it actually makes me realize how
pretty useless he wasn't the anime one
he even finds an elephant trapped in a
hole and uses his ingenuity to get him
out that's actually very nice scene but
it's botched when Bagheera finds them
both and tries to take Mowgli back to
the man village
you see when he tells Blu that Sher Khan
is after him blue for no frickin reason
lies to mowgli about why he has to go
maybe it's time for you to mosey along
we're buddies aren't me no we were never
friends I mean I certainly never thought
of you as my friend do I have to spell
this out I don't want you around anymore
okay look this Indian to me one is kind
of lame too cuz Mowgli was being a brat
but Baloo still tells him the truth and
it's Mowgli's constant fear of the man
village that drives him away in this
version Blu convinces him to stay in the
jungle Mowgli was actually gonna go to
the man village even without Bagheera so
why the hell doesn't he just be honest
go to the village or sheer Khan will
kill the shit out of you he only knows
how dangerous he is in the original he's
never seen him before but here he got
attacked by him several times so yeah go
to the man village come visit we'll hang
out just like the original plan we had
it turns out to not be fun for you I
will walk you right down to that man
villager myself just till winter there
is no goddamn reason for this pitifully
forced friendship breakup it's lazy it's
done in a million movies to create a
third act rip and it's lazy the book
didn't need him lying the anime wanted
to eat him lie but this one does because
it's the grown-up version hey you know
what's grown-up treating kids with
respect and being creative in what you
teach them you lazy assholes okay so
what characters have a main appearance
yet monkey that's right monkeys kidnap
Mowgli and take him to a temple where
King Louie voiced by Christopher you bet
your ass they made this joke walkand
resides who in all fairness
actually kind of good an Ivan Koenig
it's a totally different tone and
attitude but it kind of works you man go
you come from the south you know who I
am I am the king of the bandar-log he's
kind of like a mafia boss soft-spoken
but intimidating he's threatening but
also weirdly engaging you want to live
here
you need a people to protect you but
just when you think this is something
untainted by stupid don't try to kid me
man come I'll make a deal with you oh my
god is this happening
I desire his man's red fire to make my
dream come true
you don't have to do this now give it a
secret man commands red flag so I can be
like you Oh will do okay so you might be
thinking Kemah this song was in the
animated one why not here because there
is no other point in the movie that a
frigging musical bare necessities is a
song but not a musical number it's a
tune Baloo teaches Mowgli and they sing
it together
this song is being used to speak and
communicate it's replacing conversation
and expressing motivation and it's the
only one like it in the movie it's like
if he had a full metal jacket when they
sing Mickey Mouse Club they're just
singing a song they all know after
battle it makes sense but it's a drill
sergeant broke out singing let it go and
everybody joined him let me frigging
goddamn ludacris this is that scene it's
frigging goddamn Ludacris Balu comes in
to create a distraction as Bagheera
saves Mowgli but before giving him out
Louie reveals that the leader of the
wolves is dead she had come killed him
again Bagheera could have relayed that
information but we have to pretend this
pointless scene wasn't a pointless scene
because again Crudup version finding
this out
Mowgli sneaks into the man village to
grab the red flower to fight off Shere
Khan a few drops of it fall and I can
see where the phrase spread like
wildfire comes from because shit the
whole jungles on fire in seconds okay
this will literally have to go from this
to this in a matter of a few minutes
even wildfire doesn't spread like
wildfire so the animals are now afraid
of mowgli for starting the fire even his
family but he throws out the fire which
is the stupidest thing he could have
done I was just doing this thing you've
done right he destroyed their home you
might as well use it for its original
intent but the animals stand behind
mowgli to say thanks for burning
everything down and why the hell did we
rise up to fight this jackass days
earlier you owe it in my teeth so the
animals rush in to take damage your Chi
or blue just rushes in and everybody
else just shows moral support what can
we do we're just killer animals we can't
fight those killer animals gets taken
down though as everyone remembers oh
yeah we can do something as Mowgli is
told not to fight him like a wolf but
fight him like a man fight him like a
man
you know what this scene needs buzzards
that sound like the Beatles it'd be as
inconsistent everything else lovey
defeat Shere Khan through his inventive
ways and he falls to his death he also
manages to convince the elephants to put
out the fires yeah they just dug holes
with their tusks and let the water there
don't give in how fast those flames
spread half of India should be afire now
and the animals honor Mowgli that night
I saw something I'll never forget
it's a little boy without a people bring
all the jungle together for the very
first time except for that other time
all the animals came together which
apparently happened so often you have a
name for the place Peace Rock you could
come to the peacefrog and find food
people side by side
don't dress this up Akira he set your
home on fire and somebody else put it
out he's the equivalent of a donkey
kicking a lantern but okay you know the
drill after all this talk of acting like
a man fighting like a man and thinking
like a man the time has come for him to
gooo absolutely nowhere interesting
change and just about every version he
goes back to the man village because
they build up that's where he belongs
but this one doesn't do that
why no goddamn clue I have no idea how
this makes anything better the story and
most of its forms is about accepting the
responsibility of who you are and where
you'll grow best but this one ends on an
image just as lazy as the writing
closing the exact same book used in the
animated film because you know you just
saw the animated film except this
live-action similar guys I don't get
this
I know objectively this isn't an awful
film if there were no bugs or other
versions it'd probably just be seen as a
passable kids flick but there is a book
and a perfectly good animated film and
nothing in this is better than either of
those the original story is aggressive
dark and full of great troops the
animated film is cute charming and full
of unforgettable characters this tries
to combine them without realising what
made them
work on their own are you gonna remember
any of these characters more than the
animated one probably not or you can
remember the language or lessons as much
as the book I don't think the movie
remembers its own language or lessons it
keeps changing so much there's a rock
that's my rock that's my rock I know
there's no real harm and enjoying this
film but leaving out what made the book
and the animated versions so enjoyable
and even important is a huge disservice
to the storytellers who understand their
medium and used it so cleverly whether
it's a delightful little kids movie
you'll return to more and more or an
epic coming-of-age story or return to
more and more this one will most likely
be looked at less and less you know what
I wanted me to do an authentic version
of this book I want so authentic that
the author's name is above the title
not directed by the idiot who directed
the mommy movie strength of a bear maybe
this version isn't as bad as I thought
and then it's our gonna guy remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
child fun International founded in 1938
this is a global child development and
protection agency it helps children
break the generational cycle of poverty
and achieve their full potential child
fund works in 27 countries assisting 19
million children and family members they
want to help deprived excluded and
vulnerable children to have the capacity
to improve their lives and the
opportunity to become young adults
parents and leaders who bring lasting
and positive change to their communities
if you look at their site in their
YouTube page you'll find many personal
stories about how they've helped so many
children become the best person they're
able to be every child deserves that
chance and this is an organization that
makes it happen click on the link and be
a big part in giving that child the
chance they need
[Music]